i haven't done a video in a week sorry
about that i was out of town visiting a
friend because you got a life life
doesn't begin and end on youtube life is
out there in life for you to experience
all right that's enough of my
motivational speech for
[Music]
today the harder they fall it's a
western revenge tale because you know
it's a western they're usually revenge
tales here's the premise there's this
bad guy out there played by idris elba
he kills this little kid's mom and dad
at the beginning of the movie then a
little kid grows up to be a man played
by jonathan majors and he's out there to
get some revenge which could have been
such a run-of-the-mill western feeling
movie but it's not this movie interjects
some great energy into it makes you feel
like a fresh take on a western and the
harder they fall is it's essentially
an amalgamation
of characters like historical western
characters cowboys and criminals alike
that are real historical figures from
the west but they're all in this movie
and this movie didn't happen but the
characters are real the characters in
this movie are based on real people you
know what i'm trying to say this is what
happens when you don't make a video for
a week you already get rusty this
movie's directed by james samuel who
obviously has a stylistic eye about him
i could just see him when he was younger
being that young kid who thought about
these really sweet scenarios in a movie
and it just didn't happen at a point he
was like all right i'll make the movie
then i always appreciate an artist or a
filmmaker like that where something just
it feels like a passion project this
movie definitely felt like that also
killer soundtrack in here a mix of vibe
of western and hip-hop musical score was
also made by director james samuel which
definitely helps the movie feel like it
has synergy ever watch a movie where
you're like the soundtrack really didn't
go with that or the cinematography might
not have mixed with the soundtrack you
know it doesn't feel like everyone was
on the same page yeah a lot of times
they're not going to be on the same page
so when you have a director doing the
music who is apparently very much on the
same page with this cinematographer it
makes it feel like it has that synergy
and the cast for the most part stand out
as very unique characters the cast is
great it's a pretty star-studded cast
jonathan magers is the lead he's the
main protagonist we saw him briefly in
loki we're going to see more of him in
the mcu some of the characters that
stand out characters played by idris
elba though idris elba's he's idris elba
in this like idris elba's the bad guy in
a western how do you think he's gonna
act he is that he's that character
strong silent type is the idris elbaway
also regina king is kind of his right
hand and lakeith stanfield is probably
one of my favorite characters in the
movie you start getting into territory
where it's like there's
some conflicting information as to how
he was introduced and how he ends up
being in the movie when he's first
introduced he's like that villain that
has a code and i was like oh villain
with a code awesome also yeah thus far
a lot of the characters i've mentioned
that stand out are the villains you know
me i love my villains and i love
villains who come across as hey i'm a
killer but also a gentleman he came
across like that then as the movie went
on he just kind of shot people in the
back and shot them when they weren't
ready to do the gunfight yet turns out
his code later on is like whoever's
standing they win of course i mean it is
realistic regardless i thought he was
great in the movie tell roy lindo also a
standout you see what i mean by really
great cast also this movie surprisingly
violent i didn't expect it to be this
violent i mean gunshot gun fight
violence i expected but then there are
moments where someone gets bludgeoned
with the butt of a pistol knocking their
teeth out the moments of violence that
bothered me the most when horses got
shot i never like animals getting shot
things that drag the movie down are the
run time did it have to be 2 hours and
20 minutes long i don't think so could
have been more in the pocket if it was a
bit shorter also as much as i really
appreciate a lot of the characters
standing out as unique there are some
characters that get shoved into the
background where it's like what do i
know about that character other than
they're really good with a rifle
not much but they're a sniper i've
noticed that a lot in movies it's like
all right all these characters very
distinct very unique and the
sniper but he's a sniper what else you
need to know i don't get that
fulfillment with all the characters like
it was leading to something and then i
just left like oh
sucks that it went down like that but
for the most part this was a
surprisingly fun time when a filmmaker's
having fun making a movie and it comes
across on screen
that's a perfect marriage right there
cause there's some movies out there a
lot of michael bay movies where i'm like
that was probably a lot of fun to make
not as much fun to watch but aside from
a couple of the flaws this movie really
hit the mark great moment's attention
between a great protagonist and a great
antagonist the gunfights are badass the
dialogue is fun you're on board for the
revenge tale it's a movie that you
shouldn't sleep on you know like if
you're up for a good time watching a
movie definitely watch it i mean you're
piggybacking on your friend's netflix
for free for a reason right here you go
i'll say this movie's worth watching and
worth buying on blu-ray all right so the
harder they fall have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you